Luffy's biggest failure was letting his
brother Ace die during the ward Marine
forts however since that catastrophic
defeat Luffy has grown into one of the
strongest characters in the entire story
which makes me wonder could Luffy have
actually saved Ace if he had all of his
powers from the current storyline and so
in this video we're going to give a gear
5 Luffy a chance to see if he can
actually turn this into this and to
start things off just like in the
original storyline Luffy arrives after
the battle has already started and for
the sake of argument basically
everything leading up to the war remains
exactly the same the Whitebeard Pirates
have clashed with the Marines and Luffy
is Falling Towards whitebeard's ship oh
wait before we get into the meat and
potatoes here I quickly want to thank
today's sponsor Opera GX my browser made
by Gamers for gamers now you might
remember that I worked with Opera for
the very first time a couple of months
ago tried out their browser for that ad
read and just have never gone back to
any of my previous browsers Opera has
just a ton of great features that every
modern browser of course should have but
you only kind of realize it once you
actually have them for yourself for
example I already showed you guys that
you can use custom animated wallpapers
in the browser like this one that I have
right now but that's really only an
aesthetic thing so what are those other
features you ask well let me tell you
first off and this was just a major game
changer for me are these sidebars here
well I have quick access to my Twitter
WhatsApp and Discord messages and I can
even contact my favorite streaming app
right here in the browser as well when
I'm gaming or editing videos Opera has
CPU RAM and network limiters so you can
get the most out of both resource
intense applications and browsing I also
love this pop-up function for videos
which I found especially helpful when
following along to tutorials in a
different app and the best thing for me
personally is any extension that works
on Chrome also works in Opera making it
super easy to switch really so if you
you finally want a browser experience
that's adequate for the year 2023 then
use my link in the description below to
download Opera GX today and now back to
the video only this time the former
strongest man alive senses that Luffy is
not just some random dude falling from
the sky instead Whitebeard senses a
threat and swings his Blade with a fully
charged conquerors hockey blast just
like he did against Roger Luffy blocks
with his own conquerors haki infused
sandals and their epic Clash splits the
skies above Marine forts however shortly
after this initial earth-shattering
Clash they both quickly figure out that
they're actually both here to save Ace
and decide to team up just like they did
in the original Marine Fort however
before we can get into how gear 5 Luffy
would completely flip this battle on its
head you might want to ask Manu how in
the world would it even be possible for
Luffy to have awakened gear 5 this early
on in the story well there are a few
plausible options here for example Luffy
could have unlocked year 5 after nearly
dying in the underwater prison in pull
down or he could have met someone else
in the grand line who taught him the
secrets of his devil fruit but since the
main point of this video is to see how
current storyline Luffy would do at
Marine for it I'll say just don't worry
about it well just assume that he has
awakened his fruit somehow that Ace is
still captured and that everything else
is basically the exact same from the
original story because as you'd expect
just this one change alone is going to
make the outcome of this war insanely
difference this time Luffy will have no
trouble getting past the common Marines
and vice Admirals with a single blast of
conquerors haki he knocks out most of
the Marines and heads right for his
brother Ace here and in this version of
the war Luffy will likely still clash
with the strongest swordsman in the
world Niha originally the warlord wanted
to test himself against Whitebeard so he
would definitely want to clash against
this overpass powered version of Luffy
so can mihawk actually take on an awaken
Luffy well we do know that mihawk is not
only a very overpowered swordsman but
basically a yonko level character able
to spar with the likes of Shanks and
swords on the top of all of this are
basically Luffy's main weakness however
one thing that you have to consider is
that Luffy would be showing off his gear
5 powers for the very first time and
just like we witnessed during the wano
arc seeing gear 5 Luffy for the very
first time can make anyone seem silly
and so when mihawk tries to swing his
giant swords Luffy blocks it with
Advanced conquerors hockey grabs mihawk
by the cape and swings him around like a
little tornado mihaku is not exactly the
type to be made fun of response with a
flurry of slashes but at this point the
wipe it Commander Vista jumps in similar
how he did in the main story so that
Luffy can continue towards Ace meanwhile
everyone who's been watching this Clash
is stunned Ace is shocked at his little
brother has gotten so powerful the
Marines are in absolute awe of this
ridiculous power that they have never
seen before and even Whitebeard who out
of everyone present here possibly knows
the most about the void Century himself
can't believe that this kid he has never
heard of has such an incredible power as
always Luffy doesn't care about what
others think though and he is simply
laser focused on freeing his brother no
matter who stands in his way but first
of all we have to recap all of the
powers that Luffy didn't have at the
original marineford war and that he now
has for example he now has Mastery over
every form of gear 4 such as bount men
tank men and snake man that he learned
while training with Rayleigh during the
time skip of course he has also mastered
future side hockey during his fight with
the Mochi man karakuri and in wano he
has learned both Advanced Armament while
in prison and advanced conquerors hockey
during his fight with the emperor kaido
and on top of all that during that very
same fight with kaido he of course
finally has awakened his devil fruit to
gear 5. and while the gear 5 powers can
look goofy at first the awakened form of
Luffy's legendary devil fruit literally
allows him to make his imagination into
reality this does explain his Firepower
such as red hawk and Red Rock and also
the impossible ways that he can bent his
body and since Luffy is without any
doubt the most creative character that
we've seen in one piece when it comes to
his powers the possibilities for these
new abilities seem pretty much endless
and with so many new powers it seems
like Luffy should easily be able to wipe
the floor with everyone at marineford
right uh not quite let's not get ahead
ourselves here we also have to consider
how the Marines might act differently if
Luffy actually showed so much power
first of all I think we do have to
assume that all of the Admirals would at
least know Armament and observation
hockey maybe even conquerors and
probably even Advanced Armament since
they even see seemed to show it when
they blocked whitebeard's shock waves at
the original war on top of that it's
also extremely likely that at least the
Admirals aokiji the ice fruit user and
Akainu the magma food user have unlocked
their devil fruit Awakening as well and
probably kizuru too and while we don't
really know we've already seen what
could be their awakened powers on Punk
Hazard where they changed the entire
landscape of the islands permanently and
so while Oda wasn't quite yet ready to
reveal those powers during the original
World Marine for it it seems fair that
the Admirals would use it now that we
already know what Awakening is from
Luffy plus the Admirals didn't really
consider Luffy a threat during the
Marine Ford War but this time around he
would be one of their main targets
because he's basically a second jonko
present at the war now as the battle
fully begins Luffy's confronted by both
aokiji and the Lightfoot user Kizer and
their combined Powers should keep Luffy
contained for now at least but keep
watching to see if they can actually
keep Luffy from freeing Ace this time
but as you know Luffy of course isn't
the only top tier fighter here during
the war or the only one with a super
broken devil fruit in a previous video
where we talked about all the devil
fruits in one piece we also talked about
how whitebeard's trema fruit has the
power to literally destroy Islands magma
fruit is confirmed to be the most
destructive devil fruit in the entire
story well in this scenario these two
would still clash just like they did at
original Marine Forts and that leaves us
with the other Warlords like the string
fruit user doflamingo and the shadow
fruit user gekkomoria to fight against
the whitebeat commanders and the
prisoners from imple Dam however this
particular part of the battle would now
be much much different now that Luffy is
fighting two of the Admirals by himself
meaning aokiji and kizeru cannot help
fight against the Whitebeard Pirates as
a result the Warlords would most likely
be quite quickly overrun meaning that
Fleet Admiral sengoku would probably
order Luffy's Grandpa GARP and the
cyborg Posse fista to enter the battle
to support the Marines another important
change would be that since Whitebeard
joined the fights way earlier this time
squirt an Allied captain of Whitebeard
never has the chance to betray him which
means he wouldn't be stabbed in the
chest which again means that Whitebeard
would be even stronger than we saw him
in the original war and even the
encircling wall that the Marines used as
a trap would be practically meaningless
because Luffy could just punch his own
holes in it as well in other words so
far things aren't really going that well
for the Marines which would definitely
lead to a kind of doing something
desperate if the battle was going so
poorly I think he would likely use his
Awakening to change the entire
battlefields into magma it would
literally be like the floor is lava only
like on a massive scale however the
Allies do have a way to counter this
Whitebeard could use his Tremor powers
to make a tidal wave that would cool the
magma and Luffy could even use gear 5 to
do something silly like blows super cold
air onto the molten rocks and so now
let's actually jump back to Luffy while
aokiji and kizaru have been doing a
pretty good job keeping him busy at some
point I think that the Phoenix fruit
user Marco who is the strongest
Whitebeard Commander would come to help
him out and this would allow Luffy time
to get away in other words Luffy would
now reach the platform where his brother
Ace is tied in his chains the fleet
Admiral sengoku is still waiting for him
here but with Luffy this strong I don't
think that the Golden Buddha would be
able to keep Luffy from freeing his
brother and on top of that with Luffy's
future site kizaru wouldn't be able to
snipe the key meaning that Luffy would
simply set Ace free then together with
Ace they just fly away and everyone is
safe right uh hardly freeing A's was the
easiest part of this entire Mission now
we'll need to see if everyone can get
out of this alive because we didn't get
this far in the original version as well
now while Ace is free wiped in the kind
who have both taken considerable damage
Marco is very much struggling fighting
against two Admirals with kizeru and
aokiji GARP mihawk and the pasifista are
overwhelming the impul-down prisoners
and the Whitebeard commanders and so the
Pirates are starting to break however
with Luffy and Ace back in the battle
everyone gets a giant boost in morale
and Luffy can even show Ace his own fire
powers such as red hawk and Red Rock now
at this point the Allies start to return
to their ships but just like the
original in Marine forts Akino targets
the reunited Brothers in exchange kizeru
now takes over fighting Whitebeard and
Akino confronts Asian Luffy Akino would
probably tempt Ace with insults just
like he did at the original War still
being the hot head that he is he would
probably turn back to try and fight a
kainu however obviously the Admiral is
still way stronger he knocks eyes to the
ground with a magna-covered fist and
then stands over him to once again land
the final blow only that this time Luffy
isn't helpless instead he appears behind
a kainu and with a furious War punches a
hole straight through akinu's chest
damn that was satisfying to look at not
gonna lie and while Ace died from a very
similar wound in the original story we
don't know if Luffy can actually defeat
a kainu even with his current powers for
example a kind who could use future
sight and then morph his body around
Luffy's punch similar to what katakuri
did with his Mochi Powers however
regardless whether kainu is still too
strong for Luffy or he actually gets
taken out here it would at least stop a
kainu from killing Ace and give
Whitebeard enough time to arrive and
Crush Akainu with an island-shattering
punch which leaves the kainu laying on
the Rock in a pretty bloody heat cracks
start then to form in the island as the
brothers and Whitebeard start getting
away joyfully laughing because of their
freedom however the battle still rages
on and it is now that the cruelest
antagonist finally arrives that's right
Blackbeard has once again joined the
party with his haunting laughter echoing
across the battlefield Blackbeard and
his new crew down on the fighters and
remember that Blackbeard was the cause
of this entire War to begin with when he
captured Ace and brought him to the
Marines he did all of this to become a
warlord and then gain access to the
underwater prison imple down so he could
then gather a powerful crew from the
imprisoned criminals and then he came to
Marine for it intending to kill
Whitebeard and steal his powerful devil
fruits only that while this time around
things turn out completely different Ace
is alive Luffy is a complete monster and
Whitebeard is no longer on their store
so while it is entirely possible that
Blackbeard would see the situation and
decide it is just not worth the risk to
keep things more interesting here let's
assume that Blackbeard actually chooses
to try and continue his original plan
and so he and his crew immediately focus
on whitebeards while wipe it might not
be a Walking Corpse like he was in the
original battle he still has suffered a
lot of damage from fighting a kainu and
he in general still has his sickness so
the donko and the Darkness fruit user
clash and Whitebeard is almost defeated
however then of course Luffy and Ace
have to LEAP in France to protect the
old man at this point sengoku arrives
crushing the Blackbeard crew just like
he did in the original war and now this
gives Marco time to come over and heal
Whitebeard a little bit and unlike his
usual Brash attitude Ace begs Whitebeard
to retreat so that he can live
Whitebeard who has now fulfilled his
goal here agrees and signals the retreat
but only after adding one last insult to
the world government by proclaiming that
the one piece is
the Marines are stunts the Ally Pirates
pull back ready to return home with a
complete Victory but the battle once
again is not done yet Akino returns and
continues to attack with the full force
of the other Admirals because at this
point the Marines are about to suffer a
humiliating defeat so even if sengoku
ordered the Admirals to stay back Akino
would likely just refuse to stop because
he just couldn't stand to let the
Marines honor be tarnished like that and
so the battle once again continues with
the kainu trying desperately to take on
the Pirates by himself more and more
lives are being lost on both sides and
then we get Kobe's moment of pleading to
stop the fighting now at this moment it
is entirely likely that I kind of would
not hesitate at all he could kill Kobe
in an instant but let's just assume that
the last main player once again finally
arrives last and just like in the
original War Shanks shows up out of
nowhere to put an end to the fighting
this time however Akainu goes all out at
Shanks he cannot stand to see another
pirate making demands of the Marines and
while we don't know how that battle
would go it is very likely that akinu
would be defeated very quickly by the
combined force of the redhead Pirates
main officers and really akina would
only survive here if the other Admiral
saved him and pulled him forcefully back
into the castle now at this point there
is no doubt that Blackbeard would
Retreat as well as he didn't even want
to face Shanks in the original War
however now we have a really interesting
situation Luffy and Shanks meet on the
battlefield as they protect the
retreating Pirates and Shanks would have
to now fulfill the promise that he made
all the way back in chapter 1 and fully
acknowledge Luffy as a great pirate the
red hat Pirates of course cheer at the
reunion and there is laughter all around
as pirates pull away from Marine forts
it is truly a complete victory for Luffy
but one that leaves us with so many
changes to story going forward so just
listen to this since Ace and Whitebeard
our life we have to consider what they
would do next year Whitebeard originally
wanted Ace to become the pirate king So
after this battle it is possible that
Luffy and Ace would become Rivals as
they searched a new world for the one
piece on the other hand Ace could also
say that he doesn't want to follow in
his Father's Footsteps which honestly
isn't very likely and he could simply
support Luffy instead Shanks of course
could also decide to go after the one
piece here just like he chose to do at
the end of wano when he first saw
Luffy's awakened for him so get ready
for the race to find love tail but
that's not even close to the biggest
change that we will discuss at the end
of this video because in fact all of
these changes at marineford would also
mean that Blackbeard's future is way
different now he only has one devil
fruit and he might not even know that
it's possible to collect two of them
because that was a bit of a gamble when
he first did it and after seeing Luffy's
Powers could black beard Target Luffy
now to try to get his devil fruit next
could we see them Clash in the new world
or would Blackbeard struggle to even
become an emperor this time since he
doesn't have whitebeard's devil fruit to
begin with but the biggest change would
of course come within the straw hats
themselves because at his current power
level Luffy definitely wouldn't need to
train so goodbye time skip I guess
instead the strides would go straight
through to the new world with a very
overpowered Luffy leading a very
underpowered Straw Hat crew fisherman
Island would be a breeze there would
probably be no need to even team up with
the warlord Trafalgar law at Punk Hazard
though they would likely still rescue
momonoscan kinemon the samurai from
juano press Rosa would be no contest as
Luffy would easily topple the flamingos
from his puppet Throne as well however
not everything would be this easy
especially for the rest of the crew
since there was no time skip Zorro Sanji
and the other straw hats would be
incredibly underdeveloped as they never
had two years to train and even learn
basic hockey if they were to be attacked
by basically any powerful enemy in the
new world Luffy would need to save them
all because they would not be strong
enough to protect themselves against any
opponent there and of course another
really interesting question is how would
the other Emperors react to Luffy's
power in the new world they certainly
wouldn't underestimate him again this
time but would kaido for example join
forces with the clear inheritor of the
joy boy title or would he and big mom
team up once again even earlier this
time to search for the one piece however
this goes down the race to find love
tale would certainly start much sooner
in the story this way and while Luffy's
incredible Powers might be enough to
bring the straw hats through to whole
cake Island and wano it is equally
possible some of the straw hats could be
defeated or even straight up killed one
other factor is that if the ward
marineford was successful Luffy may
never have matured Beyond where he was
pre-time skill I mean the crushing
defeat at the original Marine Ford
almost destroyed Luffy it forced him to
grow up and train so that he could
actually be strong enough to protect his
friend and Lead as a strong captain and
so if none of that had happened then 17
year old overpowered Luffy could still
be too immature and eventually lead his
crew into trouble later on in the story
which actually leaves us with another
Super interesting question we saw that
gear 5 Luffy was able to save Ace in the
all-out ward Marine Forge and this would
likely make him the world government's
number one target so we do have to ask
what would happen if Luffy was
eventually captured by the world
government himself and said to be
executed just like Ace who would come to
save him in other words what would
happen if Luffy was going to be executed
by the Marines Shanks for watching